we've been talking all week about how
this is a huge sports weekend it's also
nascar weekend out at the speedway
hector mejia shows us how las vegas is
proving once again it is the sports and
entertainment capital of the world
there's so much going on this weekend
three days of nascar playoff races here
at the speedway in fact and this will be
the first time they'll get to have full
stands in over 18 months the las vegas
motor speedway is expecting upwards of a
hundred thousand fans through the
weekend
no vaccine or mask requirements outside
in the stands a couple of experiences
are coming back this year including neon
garage where fans get to interact with
the drivers
the fans tell us nascar weekend is all
about family time former las vegas local
john han singer flew back to the valley
to meet up with his son we've been doing
this since he was tiny and now he's
doing with his kids and it's i mean i
just i just flew in last night from
tennessee the best part is just this
just camping and just having a good time
we also met a nascar driver las vegas
local matt jaskul and he's got quite a
story this will be his first time racing
in nascar professionally and he has a
grand entrance planned for saturday's
race he'll parachute out of a helicopter
from 5 000 feet during driver
introductions and he'll go straight to
the car to race and it all starts
tonight with the truck race xfinity
series tomorrow it all wraps up with the
south point 400 on sunday reporting from
the las vegas motor speedway hector
mejia live local now